I'm Adam Thea I'm here with leech report
I'm playing start bench cut all right
I'm gonna start Friday Night Lights
I'm going to sit Rudy and I'm gonna cut
remember the babies it was tough because
those three are are obviously the best
of the best so I didn't want to cut any
of them but I had to go start super
speed I would sit super strength and I
was cut to love so deep telepathic cut I
would start Serena Williams she's one of
the best ever do it
I would bench Tiger Woods and I would
cut Tommy you know Tiger Woods was you
know he made me want to play the game of
golf
okay I'm obviously gonna start chilly
and I'm going to bench on a bench pizza
and I'm going to cut wings I'm at a
feeling and I just played start bench
cut with bleacher report and I'm here
with Hormel chili they donated a yard of
chili for every yard I gained at this
NFL season which was over 20,000 cans of
chili and over 2500 yards even though I
didn't get that many they said I would
have buy one got hurt so I had to go
with that